[Music]
hello my name is caleb denby and this is
the end game class so ignore everything
you just saw on your screen
we're not talking about um any exchange
slav games today as we were on the road
2000
but we are talking about important end
games
uh specifically rook end games that no
one really understands
and everybody messes up um i got the
idea for this class
because i myself am working through a
very famous chess book by the name of
devaretsky's endgame manual
and there's a lot of really useful uh
and really tough
information in that book so i wanted to
take some of the most important things
in these rook end games and hopefully
explain them at a level
that more people can understand because
i think
a lot of people no offense to my chat
room but i think a lot of people who
watch these streams if they try to go
through that book
they are going to struggle a bit because
i myself
am struggling quite a bit with some of
these ideas
so pretty complex stuff tonight but i'm
hoping that i'll be able to explain it
in a way
that is understandable for you guys so
to start with we're actually not going
to look at this game first this is a
very famous rook end game
and which is uh an example shown in
devretsky's and game
and game manual but first i wanted to
start with some
really useful uh theoretical ideas to
know
so first and foremost let's talk about
what happens when there's no pawns on
the board
on this side and we have one pawn
sort of in away from the kings all the
way on the seventh rank in this case
we're looking
at a rook pawn but this could be a
knight pawn it doesn't change
too much about the the position well
actually
it it might but in this case we're
dealing with a rook pawn i i don't want
to make too many bold claims unless i'm
100
certain i've like fact checked myself on
everything but
let's talk about a rook upon so what's
the evaluation of this position
well while you might expect uh might
might expect it or might already know it
this is of course
uh is a draw why is it a draw
well the fact of the matter is white is
unable to support this pawn
with the king at surface level you might
think it's a draw because black can just
run the king to the queen side
take this pawn off the board and that's
sort of the end of the story but that's
where you would be wrong
black actually has to keep this king on
two very specific squares
in this end game why is that well we see
if let's say king f1 if black
does get a little bit anxious and
decides he wants to try to go capture
this pawn
white has a really useful tactic here in
the form of rook
to h8 what is the idea the point now is
if you take this pawn
i will check you and take your rook and
win the game
if you don't take this pawn i'm going to
make queen
so if something like king f6 trying to
avoid the stroke h8 idea
now with the king off the seventh rank
you can actually get checked
and i will again promote to a queen on
the next turn
so black is going to have to keep this
king either on g7
or h7 in order to draw the position the
bad news for white
is that he can just do that there's
nothing stopping black from doing that
in this case
so let's see what it's going to look
like even though the black king is out
of the game
why is it still a draw well we see
that's even if we allow this white king
up the board
say rook a6 rook a1
once the king gets close to the pawn
black is
always able to check this king and
there's
actually no shelter anywhere on the
board for this white king to hide from
checks
so because of that the only way to go is
to come back down
but once you come down you're obviously
not helping this pawn out anymore
and it's just a draw we're starting off
pretty basic here i think a lot of
people in the chat probably already know
this
but they might not know if the position
changes
when you add two g pawns on the board
maybe you do know what happens maybe you
don't know what happens but
regardless let us talk about it here
what happens if you add two g pawns on
the board
uh first chat i want to turn it to you
can anybody tell me
what happens when there are two g pawns
on the board great wolf asks
what if the pawns on a6 instead and
we'll talk about that as well
before we get into the the game examples
but first i want to introduce
uh this variation rather than moving the
pawn back a square
let's talk about this particular
variation
chess king says this is still a dead
draw
but do you know why this is a
dead draw
do you know why
jonathan says drawn but precarious for
black
and that is actually going to be the
wrong answer i'm going to blow your mind
here
first of all i think black is probably
able to hold on to this pawn
in this variation but let's say
black was feeling a little bit risque
right and he just checks this king of
the board
and he says you know what have my pawn
have my g-pawn for free the fact of the
matter is
this is still a draw why is this still a
draw
well black well white has all the same
problems as before
and having an extra g pawn actually
doesn't change anything
doesn't change anything for white
the best white can do is push this pawn
up the board
let's say black allows this but this
pawn gets to g6
this king is on g7 there's nothing you
can do
now if you remember from last week and
i'm saying i'm not saying black has to
play like this but black
can play like this is the point even if
we try to give up this a pawn and win
with our g
pawn with the black king in front of the
pawn like this
this is just going to be a very simple
draw again black is going to retreat to
the back
and give checks to the white king from
behind
so with g pawns on the board nothing
changes now let me ask you
about this chest position does anybody
know the evaluation
of this chest position here
peter peterson says is it still a draw
with the g sit with pawns on g6 and g5
and yes it 100 is a draw with pawns on
g6
and g5 it's the exact same story
the exact same story where black doesn't
even
need the pawn
eclie ecleastic ecleastic says
win but why why is it a win
tell me
tell me the reason
use the f pawn to distract black's king
aren't we getting a little bit ahead of
ourselves i'm not asking you about
the evaluation of this position i'm
asking you about the evaluation
of this position there's a pawn in your
way
there is a pawn in your way good sir
good sirs and madams
there's a pawn in your way you can't
just push this
so i don't want to drag this out for too
long because we have a lot to get to but
this
is in fact a winning position for white
white can
actually force the wind of this f-pawn
uh which is
pretty interesting the way that white
does it is actually
through the use of zhuxvan uh without
zoozwang
white would not be winning this pawn but
of course that
is going to be a tactic here black can
shuffle the king back and forth between
g7 and h7
forcing white to take this path
black can't escape with the rook now the
king will come up the board
king g7 let's say we're back to a1 king
c5
let's say we pass king d6
let's say we pass now
white to move and win
who sees the idea
who sees the idea
does anyone see the idea i wonder
uh chess king says black goes rook a5
and you would be correct
black does have this resource to defend
the f pawn which is going to make your
life
a little bit more difficult than you
might have imagined
then chess king says ah rook c8s
i'll give you a hint while this is
sometimes an idea
in these end games you may have actually
seen a very
similar position this is never going to
be winning for white
never going to be winning the black king
is in front of your pawn
so the idea is to put black in
zugsvang how do you do that well this
black rook only has
one square on the a file where it both
defends the f
pawn and stops white from removing the
rook
in order to promote and that square is a
five
so once the rook goes to a5 what can
black
do if white is already attacking the
f-pawn well the only thing black can do
is move the king so now is there any way
for you to stop both the king shuffling
back and forth
and well to stop the king from shuffling
back and forth
while at the same time attacking the f
pawn to make this rick move off of the
crucial
a5 square and win the game and it turns
out the answer
is yes the trick is you don't go king e6
when rook a5 would make it white's turn
when you have no choice but to unimprove
your king
but what you do is go king e5
when after rook a5 check ego king e6
what's the difference now it's black's
turn if this rook leaves we take the
pawn
and if king h7 king f6 zugsvang has been
achieved the rook
must leave the defense of the pawn and
we take
what's the big deal why is this one
winning when the g
pawn wasn't well even though
black is able to set up a blockade
of the f6 square we can in fact
still play pawn to f6 check with the
point being
if the rook takes our rook leaves the a8
square and we promote
and if the king takes we check and if
the king block kids
again this tactic of rook h8 comes into
play
so this initial position is dead lost
for black because white has this nice
idea of picking up the f
pawn by the use of the zugzwang so why
are we spending our time
on these technical you know simplified
end games
well the fact of the matter is this
stuff is really
important to know for the much much much
more common scenario
of when both sides have three pawns on
the king's side
and we're dealing with one outside past
pawn
why is it important to know this stuff
well because a lot of the drawing ideas
and the winning ideas rely on a
knowledge of these basic
structures so if you ever find yourself
in a game
facing an option to leave yourself with
f pawns or g pawns or maybe you're the
defending side and you're trying to
force it
to be g pawns left on the board or f
pawns on the board if you're
on the you know the pressing side it's
really important to understand
that this end game easy win g-pawns easy
draw
okay is everybody with me so far now
since we're talking about rook pawns i
did want to mention
this vankura idea that many people in
the chat room have seen before
so what's the evaluation of this
position well it does turn out to be
a draw um why is it a draw
not because again you have this idea of
running the king to the queen's side
this again is going to fail it's the
king steps to e7
we see a7 the king is too far away to
come back
and now you can do nothing more than
delay the inevitable
when rook h8 is coming and winning the
game
so what's the drawing idea it's not the
same drawing idea
of just waiting because if you just wait
now my king can actually come to a
useful square
that square is a7 when i do have shelter
from checks
but of course the drawing idea here is
to again check the king forever how can
we do that
well we use the idea of checking from
the side
because there again is no shelter from
checks from the side of the board
how do we manage that well it's not with
the vancoura idea many of you have been
exposed to with the movarek f1 check
that would be a critical mistake in this
case because
rook f6 would lose to rick g8 check so
be careful
but with the king over here stopping our
rook f6 idea
we can just go rook c1 when now
after king here we bring our rook to the
sixth rank this is the critical idea
if it gets pushed away we stay on the
sixth rank
and the second that this rook touches
the a pawn
we start giving checks from the side and
force the king back
away and this is the drawing idea by the
way
if you ever go a7 now we transition
to the drawing idea we've seen
previously with the rook behind the pawn
and checks from behind also by the way
don't even think about stepping to this
square when now you are in fact
going to lose the game stepping either
here or here with the rook
how are you losing the game um not with
that idea but
in fact with king b5 because now once
again
there is shelter from chex because your
king is in the way so that's the vankura
idea you put the rook on the sixth rank
and
you check the king from the side
now i did want to jump back to a real
life
game so let's look at this game between
michael bodfenik
and isaac blislovsky now since this is
an endgame class
i don't care about any of what's
happening here this is all
garbage what are these chess moves so
complicated
oh okay nice little tactic here by
botfonic by the way
takes queen takes e8 transposing into a
winning
end game so in this position we are
actually going to talk
a little bit uh about something
different
than what we were just mentioning so
what were we just mentioning
we were just mentioning all of the
positions with the rook
stuck in front of the pawn and the pawn
on the seventh rank or in one case the
sixth
but let's talk about the slightly
simpler version
that we're looking at here for white so
white to move
what should white do here
pip and chuck asks who even realized
that that was winning for white
honestly i probably should have credited
somebody but i
don't know didn't do the research don't
know who figured it out
don't know who figured it out first
somebody long dead they figured that one
out a while ago so i don't feel too bad
don't feel too bad and yeah you guys
have the right idea
rook b1 is an absolute must play for
white you can avoid many of the stupid
complications
of what we just talked about by simply
playing rook b1 rook b1
is quite easily winning here for
white now conversely what should black
do
in order to try and save this game
um yeah i think chess and math sort of
have a good relationship
uh historically i think there were a lot
of good mathematicians that were also
chess players
i have always been decent at math but
nothing too crazy
so you know the famous triash rule is
rooks belong behind past pawns and
that's the case here
but with black what's the best way to
try
to defend well it turns out in order to
have any chance of saving these end
games
you want to stop this pawn as early as
humanly possible
so the only real try here for black is
rook c6
point is after b5 you go rook b6 and
begin to try uh you know the long
arduous task
of holding this game now in the game
uh we are gonna look at the defensive
side next but first let's look at what
happens
if black plays as boloslovsky did with
something simple like king f7 now with
white
you should push this pawn as far forward
as you can
with the caveats that you always have to
calculate first
why do you have to calculate first well
that question becomes very relevant
in this position should white play the
move b7
and what do i mean by calculating what
are you trying to calculate if you play
the move b7
should b7 be played here yes or no chat
i'll also accept you telling me what you
have to calculate before playing b7
what should you calculate before you
play this move
why not rook b8 because the king is
closer to that square so black is going
to
be playing rook b8 here but we'll talk a
little bit more about that defensive
side
as we get into it butts
b7 yes or no everybody says no
no no no but why not why not b7
the fact of the matter is if you can
play b7 you should play b7 the further
advance this pawn is
the better for white but the unfortunate
truth of it
is that if you do play b7 you
need to have calculated first b7
actually blows the wind
blood why does it blow the wind well
white has spent a little bit too much
time pushing the pawn
and forgot to activate the king so now
black is actually able to draw with the
simple idea
of running the king to the pawn and
trading into the king and pawn end game
black is in time to get back to the
king's side
and stop the critical move king e6 and
draw
the game so if you are busy pushing your
pawn up the board you always have to be
certain
that this plan of action doesn't work
for black which i should mention is why
these positions are almost always
winning for white
they're winning because black can never
actually take this pawn off the board
it's too far away and the white king is
able to invade
and uh you know win
so in the game botfnik of course
realized this and plays the move h3
with the idea of activating the king we
see king d5
again b7 i think would be premature king
c6 king g3
and it's exactly what we just looked at
so instead simply king g3 king c6
king g4 and now
how do you try to draw the position with
black what do you guys think
black to move and find the drawing idea
not saying it works but what should
black do
to try to draw
and by the way the chat was saying they
wanted to activate the king via g1
i that was also fine not nothing wrong
with that i should mention
nothing too wrong with that
although maybe just just to be
you know a little bit of a devil's
advocate here king g1
rook f8 and you might be tempted here to
play b7
but again i think that leads to a draw
so this idea though is enough to
activate the king
anyways king g4 the drawing idea for
black
so yeah there is a crucial question that
the
chat room is split on it's whether to
blockade this pawn with the king
or with the rook and it turns out the
only real way to try and draw
is to blockade with the king to free up
the rook to help defend the king's side
if you do blockade with the rook this is
going to be a bit easier
on white to uh to crack here uh you
simply just push these pawns up the
board
let's say black passes because what else
can you do push the pawns up the board
black passes because what else can you
do push the king up the board
black passes you push black passes
and at the end of the day what is
actually going to happen
well white's going to push h6 takes
takes
let's say you pass now it's just a
matter of time
before we sacrifice our b pawn
in return for the h pawn can't take
because i'll check
rook c7 and that's going to be the end
of
the game right there notably even if
something like this
i think still rooks c7 and the g pawn
will queen
it's as simple as that for white so
the only real drawing idea is to
defend against this pawn with the king
that's really all you can do
i should also say if you defend with the
rook and think
you are going to come to the king side
with your king i'll even give you time
to do it
this idea is also not going to be enough
for a draw
because now we can leverage threats of
coming to the queen side with our king
along with playing on the king's side
with our king as well for example
let's say you pass king e4 king e6
uh h5 for example you can't even waste
tempe with the rook because i'll push
the pawn
king f6 king d5 wins king d6
5 wins this is much easier for white to
win
as well so our last idea
is to blockade with the king and
now chat room right to move and win what
should be played
chess king says i think black plays a6
before white i assume you mean h6 in one
of the lines that i was showing
and shirt then i'll play king g6 and my
idea will be the same i sacrifice my
b-pawn
take your kingside pawns and win the
game
here though this is black's best try
king b7
with the point that we are blockading
with the king to free up the rook
so white to move and find the winning
idea
it's not too late to mess this one up
not too late to mess this one up
pip and chuck says h4h5h6 and sure let's
let's take a look so let's say you play
the move h4
let's say you play the move h4 now the
power
of this king b7 idea is that we are
stopping this pawn
with the king we are immobilizing this
rook with the king as well
and now black is actually quite happy to
play
with the rook against the king on the
king's side what's the difference
well you're not gonna not run into any
of those pesky uh sorry excuse me any of
those pesky opposition ideas
that we were dealing with here right
here black had to waste a move with the
king
and white's king was able to invade on
one side of the board or the other
versus now if we are blockading with
the rook um good luck
ever crossing the fifth rank with your
king good luck
ever crossing the fifth rank with your
king and i mean ever
and if you try to come to the queen side
of the board good luck with that as well
i'm gonna start taking all your pawns
right i'm gonna start taking all your
pawns
and you're not even winning on this side
of the board anymore with my king
in front you know we we know this from
our basic study
on last week so
h4 throws away the win and in fact any
move here
i believe throws away the win aside from
one idea
what idea is that well you actually
transfer
the rook from behind the pawn to the
side of the pawn
with the move rook e1 this is the
crucial winning idea here for white
and it's important one to know it's an
important one to know because i don't
think
there's really any other way to win this
game with white aside from this idea
of transferring the rook to the side of
the pawn
now why is this working well the point
here for white is that this is
uncapturable due to rook b1 check when
we would trade into a winning king in
pawn end game
this one is not a draw because we get to
e6
and behind the pawns and now
rookie 6 is just unstoppable rook g8 was
played in the
game which is the best try notably if
you go anywhere else i can simply take
all these pawns
so rook g8 played now rook e6 and
what's the point well the point is now
we have the same ideas of attacking on
the king's side
but white is the one playing with extra
material now rather than a king versus a
rook on its own
try and make something happen on the
king's side which is just impossible
we have the rook and the king working
together to attack the king's side
while white's rook also defends the pawn
on b6 and this is the winning idea
um in the game black tries this move
king
a6 we see king g5 by white king b7 black
has nothing better than to pass here
notably if you move this rook again
rookie 7
takes and this is just a win
the black king is far too far away and
you're never really able to hold on to
this pawn
king h5 king h6 tough to stop
so that's why you see black passing we
see white just advancing up the board
now
h5 g4 king h4
and how do you make something happen
well it's the same idea that we saw
before
with h6 this is just the way to
break through if black plays h6 by the
way
now you have to worry about this guy and
it's
it's sort of even simpler than before
now
we can number one just run our king all
over the board
or perhaps even simpler go with
this pass and then um
even king g4 for example and h6
why king g4 well i didn't want to get
checked and this is
as simple a win as they come
okay so in the game though we see h6
g takes rook takes now rook g7 to defend
the final pawn we see king h5 king a6
and now right to move once again see if
you can find
the simplest way to win this game
steve says wow only works because the
pawn is on the b file if
it was on the c file or closer then the
white king cannot get to e6 in time
um i don't feel comfortable responding
to that question with a definite answer
because
i have not have not done the analysis
there
toblerone says who's the greatest
endgame artist
you vote kept blanca cappa blanca was
definitely the first
real great end game player i would say
chess king says g5 and okay i won't
waste too much of your time here i think
every move wins to be honest every
reasonable move at least
but in my opinion the simplest and
easiest is actually to go
rook c6 with the idea that the time is
right
to give up um this pawn
king b7 of course would be uh horribly
losing
in the king and pawn end game in the
actual game black tried rookie 7
but white's idea is still to give up
this pawn and go for
a winning rook and pawn end game we see
king b6
rook h7 king e6 and now
white simply pushes this pawn and with
the king able to get in front of the
pawn
the black king cut off it's going to be
a simple win
by virtue of the lucina position rook a1
g7 check check check
king e7 and now of course white to move
and win
we've all seen this one before if you
watched last week's last
week's lecture you go rookie two check
king d7
rookie four and king f7
building a bridge with the rook and here
is where black decided to throw in the
towel and resign
so very instructive end game on the rook
being behind
the pawn i should state by the way g5
these moves
all win the game as well black is still
sort of forced into this
passivity and it's it's only a matter of
time before
the the end uh kind of arrives
and actually i i do have a table blaze
open this is even b7 wins which is a
little bit surprising to me but
apparently even this wins
what's the idea
ah this is the idea okay but it's a bit
unnecessary
to get the pawn like that perhaps we
should just start with this
when again we are taking this h pawn and
winning with g6 so
questions on this end game with the rook
behind the pawn preferably questions
that i can answer
because this question of would this be
winning if the pawn was a bishop's pun
those types of questions i i can't just
answer off the cuff
um these end games are more case-by-case
basis
than i think a lot of people realize and
is it winning if it's a bishop's pawn
my gut instinct would be yes it's still
winning somehow
but um probably the the difference is
the white king would have to be closer
before going for these
these ideas you might not be able to
push the pawn as far
in order to ensure that you're still
winning the king and pawn on games
so complicated no way you could find
these awesome moves in an end game
and you actually didn't use the word
awesome i don't know where i came up
with that
but the point of the lecture is to
introduce you to these ideas
so first and foremost we had this idea
that everybody kind of knew put the rook
behind the pawn
then we have this idea to push it as far
forward as possible
but you always want to ensure that the
ensuing king and pawn end game is
winning
that's why you don't see the pawn to b7
and then the critical idea that i think
is new to a lot of people
is when the king starts to blockade the
pawn you do want to make the switch
to guarding the pawn from the side not
guarding the pawn
from behind from then it's just a matter
of forcing a weakness on the king's side
and eventually sacrificing your pawn for
the king side pawns
that's the winning method here
can i make it a quick summary i think
that's what i just did hopefully
but let us move on to another rook and
pawn end game and i want to look at this
one from the defensive side
and again it's going to be everybody's
hero mikhail
botfenik so again this is an endgame
class this is all
garbage i don't know what this is i
don't know what this is okay this is an
end game but
it's not technical enough for us uh i do
want to say
very nice move here by botfonic to go
for the draw
in these end games where you're upon
down and trying to draw you want to
liquidate as much as possible
get pawns off the board which is why
this move b4
is a good one in the game you see rook
a3
bc5 and now botfnik is able to
leverage the c pawn against one of the
queen side pawns unfortunately not both
of them
otherwise it would be simple and get to
this position uh here rook takes b3 is
the idea
rook takes c7 rig a3 rook a7
and here white to move white to move
what should white play
steve says is that why you start with a
blockade with the rook on v6 so you can
replace it with the king
so yes steve that that is the idea
although i i do want to say in that
first example
it's not quite as clear as i would have
liked we can take a look at it
but this example is a lot more clear of
of a drawing idea
for white
so what should we start with here with
the white pieces
what should we start with here
how do you start and yet eduardo has the
right idea
you must stop this pawn in its tracks as
early as possible
why is that well we're gonna see in just
a moment
so rook a4 is definitely definitely
definitely
the best move in the position you stop
this pawn in a5 before it gets to a4
and that matters for the reason that um
i believe it was peter
uh same reason that maybe it wasn't
peter
it was the same reason that steve just
said
uh partially for that reason where when
you uh keep the pawn further up the
board
sometimes you have these ideas replacing
the rook with the king and using the the
king
the rook to try to draw but also in
every variation
there are going to be times when your
king king or rook
need to leave the pawn and if you need
to leave the pawn
it's much better to have three tempe to
spare
than two tempe despair than one tempe to
spare right you want this pawn as far
back as possible
to give you these active ideas on the
other side of the board
so that being said king g5 is what was
played in the game
and here who can tell me a really really
crucial
drawing idea for white how should white
ever try to draw this game what do you
guys think
what can be done
what's can be done
yeah great wolf says spend a tempo now
to save a tempo
later and not only that it's
sort of like the okay i think i've
already explained it but yes
great wolf essentially has the right
idea there though it is not always that
simple
that you know it's not immediately
obvious why a tempo now is worth less
than the tempo later but we
shall see at the end of this fine
crusoe says trading all the pawns
unfortunately
trading all the pawns is not really an
achievable
goal for white white has one really
important idea
in mind here and
the crucial drawing idea for white in
these end games
is to make a past pawn
so let's see how bottoming goes about
doing it and then we'll see
why it's such a good idea for white so
what botfinec starts with here
is the move pawn to f3
why is this move so good well the point
is
black really only has one idea and that
is to bring the king to the pawn on
the queen side this is what we see
black trying to achieve there's no other
way to sort of force this rook away
and it's not like the king is going to
break through to the king's side
when again we have our rook in such an
active position
sort of a stark difference to the
position we just saw right in the
previous position
we saw the white king
able to sort of attack the king's side
uninhibited because
the pawn was further advanced imagine
for example the
rook on a2 and the pawn on a3 then
this becomes a very relevant winning
idea whereas now the king will have
to evict this rook before um before
going
for anything on the king's side so this
is the crucial idea to start with
for black now white is going to play the
move
g4 and this is the point of f3 we go g4
pawn takes should be played if you don't
take
now white is going to go here here and
white to move in this position does
anybody have it
wait to move here
what can white do
what can white do
am i one of the kids from that
beginner's kids video uploaded seven
years ago
maybe i did attend a few classes when i
was a bit younger
but i wasn't exactly a regular so it's
sort of a
sort of unlikely
so you guys have your heart in the right
place but
the wrong specifics so you are correct
to want to go after the weakness that we
just created on
h5 white's idea is to create a past pawn
for counter play
however rook h4 is not the way to do
that rook h4
and unfortunately for you your rook is
too far away to catch this pawn
too far away you just can't get there in
time
can't get there in time so rook h4 not
the way to do it
but you do want to go after this pawn
but you do so with
the king and the point now is that black
is
far too slow on this side of the board
compared
to us on our side of the board rook a1
a4 king h5 and now
we will be able to take black's last
pawn and
fight back with our own past pawns over
here
um even if for example
rook h7 uh here
white has a really nice idea of a
frontal attack on the pawn which is an
idea i don't think i've introduced yet
maybe i should have for this one a
specific reason but i kind of forgot
this was an important idea
uh in this particular um position
i think there are other ways to draw
here for white by the way like this
isn't necessarily forced
but a really useful idea to remember is
you can
in this particular position just keep
the black pieces at bay
with this particular idea of checking
and attacking the pawn from the front
and black is not able to really do
anything against this
um okay so that's what happens if king
e5 we go g takes h5 and we go after this
pawn on h5
and push our h pawn and take this f
does everybody understand that does that
look complicated still to anybody it's
fine if it does because these are pretty
complex ideas
it's fine if it does
toblerone says it looks quite simple
fair enough but
life isn't always so easy h takes g4 is
a bit of a better try
now king e5 and black's pawns are not so
easy to attack we can't exactly get
after that guy
with our king so white to move here what
should be played
what should be played
white to move in this position
and yeah torches has the right answer
here
once again we don't necessarily have to
win pawns on the king's side all we have
to do
is make a past pawn and the way to do
that is with pawn h4
now king d5 for example is the only
winning tribe played in the game
h5 takes takes and now it's very clear
that black's efforts on the queen side
of the board are not going to be
fruitful we can just push this pawn
forward
support it from behind now black is the
one who has to be careful
and guard against this h pawn coming
forward
and white is in zero danger here
in zero danger any move draws for white
okay well now probably we should we
should we should stop this pawn i should
mention
so king e3 a3 it is worthwhile to stop
this pawn otherwise a2 in rook takes h6
comes
but still no danger at all here for um
for white
by the way drawing idea here for white
again no shelter for this king
check back it's a draw
it is a draw so instead
black in the game tries to go king e6
h6 king f7 with the point being
that black is now going to try and
capture our h
pawn so what can white do this what can
white do here
it's tour five not tor understood tour
five
understood
white to move and draw
you understand that my name is my name
is nobody um
yeah the problem is i am trying to
explain these ideas
but these are the types of rook end
games
that everybody including very high level
players can often get wrong
so i think no one is almost a fair
assessment of that
um as i said a lot of these positions
come from duveretsky's endgame manual
which i'm working through myself
and there are even some positions where
um
i think almost a direct quote is like
and here i don't
dare judge whether white's position is
enough for a win you know
it's like he's like i think this is
white's best try but i i can't even
judge if this is enough
so yes the correct idea is the critical
move rook
g4 rook h4 by the way is actually going
to lose the game in this case
to king g6 when our pawn is
dead ever so sadly so rook g
just just to highlight here king g6 king
f2
um our pawn does die uh to rook h7
and okay well actually hold on our pawn
does die
but hold on our pawn dies to king h7
blockading the pawn
when eventually our rug will have to
sacrifice itself for the a4 pawn
took me a little bit to get there but no
reason to calculate all that
you just go rook g4 cutting the king off
and drawing the game a4 would be a
mistake
in light of rook g7 check and rook takes
a7
so king f8 was played in the game but
now
we start to see the power of white's
idea rook
f4 on his attacks so rook a6
defending the pawn but now rook g4
threatening h7 so rook a7 stopping h7
but now rook f4 threatening black's pawn
and black gave it the only try he could
with king g8
to stop h6 giving up this pawn pushing
up the board
but now white isn't plenty of time to
get in front of the pawn
go king f2 go king e3 and white's king
is their first drawing the game
so to recap the drawing idea here for
whites
is number one stop this pawn as early as
possible
number two try to create a past pawn or
a weakness that you can attack with the
king
on the king's side of the board and then
use that past pawn as a decoy
to keep black from making progress on
the other side and
draw the game as we see um notably by
the way
ideas like this don't work either h7 is
coming
and again nothing doing here for uh for
black
can even take on a4
okay so questions on this end game
before i explain how this end game is
not as simple as it may seem now
questions here before i talk about you
know how it's actually not all so simple
all right well then let's talk about how
it's not so simple so what could black
have done differently well let's
first examine this position uh perhaps a
better try for black
would have been king g5 and what's the
point of king g5
well the point is you know it may be
true
that you are threatening to make a past
pawn but by playing this move g4
you may have given my king an inroad to
the king side
with the winning idea that we saw from
the first game
fortunately for white you are able to
stop this king from invading quite
easily you go king g2
king h4 and now h3 and black
passes but you can pass as well
right so let's say g5 king h2
and well okay with g5 you're obviously
still mating your own king and
committing this idea but black could
have passed any other way and again king
h2
is the response so blacks perhaps only
winning try here
is to try and go after the kingside
pawns directly
giving up the a pawn if you don't do
this
then you are simply not making progress
on this side of the board
f5 is only playing into white's idea
of making a past pawn so
g5 king h2 rook b7
rook takes a5 rook b2 check king g1
king takes h3 who knows the evaluation
of this position who knows the
evaluation of this position
think back to last week's lecture on
basic rook endgames because that's gonna
come in handy here
eduardo asks what if there's an other
another line besides h6 g4 so we looked
at what happens if black ignores the g4
pawn
white takes on h5 and targets it with
his king
tor five chests says rook a3 or k4 uh
means rook a4 yeah rook a4 is not going
to be good enough
not going to be good enough here you are
losing that guy
kabu says draw mario says rook f5 rook
f5
not gonna be good enough rook b6 and
you're losing that guy
two pawns two pawns is good
two pawns is good
rook a6 well king takes g4
are you drawing after rook a6 king takes
g4 you're right that rook 86 is the best
try
but are you drawing after king takes g4
are you drawing after king takes g4
so good job finding our k6 we spotted
the tricks now for black
but are you drawing after king g4 this
is the question
and the answer of course is yes
why are you drawing well because it is a
knight's pawn
and if you guys were paying attention in
lecture number one
last week you'll know that after king g3
rook f1 we have the passive defense and
this
is enough against the knights pawn we
simply shuffle our rook back and forth
on the first rank and cannot lose so
well done to anybody who spotted that
you're okay rook b1 by the way doesn't
change anything
white is still easily drawing here
so rook a6 and white barely draws
against this idea of king g5 king h4 so
maybe both players spotted this in the
game but this would have been a bit of a
better try
uh remembering that you always have to
be careful when you make
inroads for the black king again just to
point out for the question asker
if black ignores this we go after this
pawn with the king and again manage
a draw and lastly maybe
in light of all these ideas king g5 was
actually a little bit wrong for example
what happens on king g7 what's the
difference
well what if we try the exact same thing
king
f7 now g4 is not coming with check
and maybe black consider playing
something like f4
trying to lock things up and this idea
could potentially be gaining in power
right how are we making a past pawn here
f4
king e7 uh maybe even king e6
but the point now is that black is going
to lock things up on this side of the
board
and it's not so clear how black how
white is making the past pawn in fact
maybe even g5 here by black is the most
accurate making sure this isn't a target
either
and the answer is i don't know what's
going on here
this would be i think a lot tougher for
white to deal with
with this plan of coming over to the
queen side coming a lot
more quickly from black so
what should white do against king g7
turns out the best line as given by
dvaretsky
is king g2 king f7 king f3
why is this better than the f3 line well
we have the same ideas that we are just
looking at
but now our king is going to help us in
our quest
to make a past pawn or make a target for
us to take
and then get a past pawn and
what is going on here well i think the
best try
for black is to go king e6
when we respond with g4 now
after h4 we can go king e4
with the point being we stop black from
invading
and we have um the nice idea of
continuing now
with the move um f4 although i'm messing
up the line slightly
okay the line i had prepared was g5 by
black first
the point now after g4 h4 white cannot
go after this pawn
if you do go king e6 now i think
g4 h4 king f4 is the idea with
g5 to follow so g5 by black and now the
point is going to be
king f5 by white or f4 followed by king
f5
again making a target just in time
so once again though black perhaps
can pose white some extra
problems here uh
how can black pose white some extra
problems hold on
let me remember my analysis really quick
g4 what was the problem
for white
honestly i'm not remembering i think
this g4 idea is enough to draw there was
one more tricky line
that i think i'm forgetting or missing
for black but this
is going to be enough for for a draw by
white um
there was some idea where black is able
to uh
force the white king back a little bit i
think if you
capture it like this for example and go
king d5
it can still be tough the idea though
once again
is simply to make a passive pawn on the
king's side
as we've seen before king b5 or k1
and now if we start pushing the pawn we
go f5 and it's impossible to stop white
from getting the past pawn
and drawing the game for example takes
or
g five is the same now
both sides same number of fast pawns and
a draw
okay
so what is the point of this defensive
idea that we looked at here
the point is that in order to draw these
positions
whites or the defending side should
strive to create a pass pawn
on the opposite side of the board to
deal with the pawn
uh that the stronger side has and that's
what we saw
work for white in this game and we saw
the winning technique for bot finic in
this case
with the crucial switching of the rook
to defending from the side
so that is unfortunately where i'm going
to have to call it for this lecture i
actually had
one more really complicated rook end
game to show you guys tonight but it
will have to wait for next week or maybe
this is where where we will call it
quits on these rock end games because i
know this stuff is really complicated
but i do think it is vitally important
to know
it will save you games or get you extra
half points
and maybe you don't fully uh deserve
them
so final questions on these rook end
games
that are answerable by by me of course
there are some answers
that no one has just yet because these
end games are
incredibly complicated
final questions
all right well i'm not saying too much
that is going to be where i call it for
tonight thank you guys so much for
joining
if you're watching live please head on
over to the twitch channel
for another edition of analyze your
games the class where i
analyze your games um and if you're
watching the youtube version that is
going to be it for tonight thank you so
much for joining me as always my name is
caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you